are some skills you are just born with
for six-year-old kashawn Todd that's
basketball check out how he schools his
dad right on their living room Court
so Christian says one of his signature
moves is throwing the ball between his
opponent's leg he and his dad Quincy
love showing off their skills on social
media they have been practicing since
kashan was two years old let's see if
used the ceiling
um playing basketball on this little
baby core and then I start when I grow
up and I played on a big corpse we just
hope to just keep inspiring people to
play the game basketball and and
ultimately uh to just have fun with the
process
the California do call themselves
hooplored and hoop Lord Jr Sean tells us
he wants to be a basketball player when
he grows up